so how do you keep getting those red
pilled liberals and those those sort of
disaffected lefties uh well you gotta
keep allowing for truth to get out there
here was a really nice moment a couple
days ago this is I would say two
liberals this is Joe Rogan and Russell
Brand calling out that unelected
bureaucratic machine the jebediah's talk
Jedediah is talking about related to
Bill Gates and covet and vaxes and more
watch the video we're thinking the best
thing might be this medication but of
course you can vote what you don't want
is the who determining that in the next
pandemic they have the right to
implement by their votes it contains
them in the who like lockdown measures
medication measures which is something
that they're lobbying for currently I
understand less and less democracy more
and more ability for unelected globalist
I would have to say globalist
organizations to assert political
influence over Nations and that's what
we saw here and like when you know that
the who's second biggest funder is the
bill Melinda Gates Foundation and he
invests so heavily into these facts
again like stuff that gets called
conspiracy theory but you can look at
the the evidences that Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation profited millions of
dollars on the vaccines millions
millions and millions of dollars it's
all easy to find and then once he dumped
the stock then he completely changed his
narrative and he started talking about
how ineffective the vaccines were and
about how the virus wasn't as bad as we
thought it was and about it was mostly
targeting old and obese people like this
is wild because this is the same
guy that threw the entire pandemic was
talking about how great these vaccines
are and these vaccines are so effective
and they stop the virus and they stop
transmission they stop infection and all
that was a lie and he profited off those
lies all right so this is good stuff
guys you may be watching that going well
I know all this stuff and okay we've
been talking about this for all but you
got to remember Rogan's got the biggest
podcast on the planet his audience is
generally I would say a bit left leaning
it's hard to say now at this point right
maybe it's a little more libertarian but
Rogan himself as far as I know in the
last election didn't even vote right so
he he this guy who's unbelievably
influential I suppose didn't have the I
don't want to exactly say it like this
he either didn't have the balls or
whatever it was he just couldn't do the
thing for Trump right even though he was
always complaining about Biden always
complaining about wokeness all of these
things right he couldn't quite get there
but now actually now that we're into
this Biden term and things have been a
little weird and all the covid nonsense
and the cognitive stuff and everything
else even Rogan now is coming out and
saying that he could do something a
little different this time and I go I
would vote for Trump before I'd vote for
Biden just because I think with Biden
like he's no he's he's gone like you
know he's gone it's you're going to be
relying on his cabinet and I knew his
cabinet would be this Sideshow
of diversity and which is exactly what
it is I mean let that one person who
stole all the women's clothes that Sam
Brinton we highlighted on the podcast
yesterday like that's a diversity hire
you you just said oh look at this a man
who dresses like a woman and has a beard
and a mustache but also wears lipstick
this is perfect for us I don't give a
what this guy's good at or bad at I
don't give a what their credentials
are this makes us look like we're
inclusive this makes us look like we're
on the right side so let's let's hire
this person and that those are the you
can't have those kind of people running
a Ben and Jerry's you you certainly
the most powerful government the world's
ever known
[Music]
thank you